[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia el 24 de octubre de 2020 se
conmemoran 75 años de la existencia
oficial de la organización de las
naciones unidas y nos surge la pregunta
que tanto prestigio y reputación tiene
este organismo tres cuartos de siglo
después de su fundación
remontémonos entonces a 1945 cuando 50
países se reunieron en san francisco
california durante las postrimerías de
la segunda guerra mundial el objetivo
era crear la carta de las naciones
unidas un compromiso firmado para
prevenir que el mundo cayera en otro
conflicto tan desgarrador como el que
acaban de presenciar así empezó el curso
de esta organización que según el libro
la gobernanza global y las naciones
unidas- un viaje en concluso ni la
asamblea general de la onu es un
parlamento mundial ni el secretario
general es el presidente del mundo otra
forma de explicar las ideas de tomás
vice y ramires thakur es que la onu
pretende mejorar la gobernanza global
más
no crear un gobierno mundial pero en los
años 90 con la disolución del comunismo
soviético la reputación de la onu estuvo
gravemente afectada luego de demostrar
una aparente impotencia para terminar el
conflicto en la antigua yugoslavia sin
embargo como repasan vice y thakur en su
libro el artículo 27 de la carta de las
naciones unidas expresa que nada de lo
contenido en la carta autorizará a la
onu a intervenir en asuntos que son
esencialmente de la jurisdicción interna
de cualquier estado criticada y
celebrada a la vez lo cierto es que por
la asamblea de las naciones unidas han
pasado los grandes líderes mundiales de
los últimos 75 años un escenario mundial
para líderes del planeta la historia de
las naciones unidas- es rica en momentos
de clímax que han provocado altos y
bajos en las relaciones internacionales
en 1960 en medio de la guerra fría el
líder soviético nikita kruschev golpeó
con furia sus zapatos sobre un pupitre
desde el que se pronunciaba
dos años después el embajador
estadounidense confrontó violentamente a
su contraparte soviética en el consejo
de seguridad de la onu
ambas usted embajador sorín niega que la
unión soviética haya instalado y esencia
de la cndh o misiles de alcance medio e
intermedio cuba no espere por la
traducción diga sí o no eso no la guerra
fría pero también la crisis de medio
oriente en 1974 ocurrió un hecho
histórico por primera vez la onu invitó
a yaser arafat el líder de la
organización para la liberación de
palestina 2
hoy he venido portando una rama de olivo
en una mano y el arma de un luchador por
la libertad en la otra no dejen que
caiga de mi mano la rama de olivo
repito no dejen que caiga de mi mano la
rama de olivo
pero los discursos no siempre han venido
acompañados de aplausos en 2003 el
presidente estadounidense george w bush
pidió una intervención militar en irak
lo que detonó acalorados debates en la
onu de ave con wash para aquellos que se
preguntan con ansiedad cuándo y cómo
vamos a ceder ante la guerra
quiero decirles que nunca en ningún
momento en el seno del consejo de
seguridad llegará el momento de
precipitarse
de la incomprensión de la sospecha o el
miedo de la suspensión de la perder la
guerra en irak comenzó un mes más tarde
tres años después el presidente de
venezuela hugo chávez polemizó en contra
de george bush y la hegemonía
estadounidense ayer estuvo el
aquí
[Música]
en este mismo lugar pelea sufre todavía
otros líderes han transformado sus 15
minutos de fama en discursos
interminables en 2009 por más de dos
horas
moamar gadafi líder libio habló de
piratas somalíes la muerte de john
fitzgerald kennedy teorías de
conspiración y críticas contra eeuu
fíjate luisa no hay absolutamente nada
escrito en esta carta que indique que
las naciones unidas tengan el derecho a
intervenir en los asuntos internos de
otros países pero su discurso no fue ni
de cerca el más largo expuesto ante la
onu
en 1962 el líder cubano fidel castro
habló por 4 horas y 29 minutos y entró
en el libro de los récord guinness más
recientemente en 2019 hablando de la
cumbre de acción por el clima de las
naciones unidas la joven activista cree
está tumba con tan sólo 16 años criticó
directamente a los líderes del mundo por
no ser lo suficientemente maduros al
momento de decir las cosas como son
la gente está sufriendo la gente está
muriendo ecosistemas enteros están
colapsando estamos en el comienzo de una
extinción masiva y de lo único que
pueden hablar es de dinero y de cuentos
de hadas de crecimiento eterno de la
economía
a diario cómo se atreven
desde los apasionados hasta los
provocativos muchos discursos
inolvidables han pasado por este
organismo internacional y son muchos los
que faltan por venir porque en las
naciones unidas
los debates sólo terminan cuando se
apagan las luces a 75 años después las
naciones unidas cuentan con 193 estados
miembros pero un año de pandemia de
coronavirus ha puesto a prueba la
efectividad del organismo para
consensuar la solidaridad de estos
países en consecuencia varios líderes
mundiales han pedido una reforma de las
naciones unidas y en específico del
consejo de seguridad pues consideran
injusto que 5 países sean los únicos
poderes permanentes con derecho a veto
en la más reciente asamblea de
septiembre de 2020 el secretario general
antonio guterres reconoció que la unión
del mundo atraviesa por momentos de
decepción hasta aquí llegamos hoy andrés
suárez jaramillo gracias por compartir
estas historias que las se encuentran en
france 24 punto com
[Música]